it's the hardest and most regal ticket
in town
and a wish come true for these hardcore
Royalists selected from more than a
thousand hopefuls to attend a party
honoring Queen Elizabeth Martin Ling
Aman is along for the ride the British
Way of life has heavily influenced his
style as has her majesty more than 3600
British soldiers lie here at the British
War Cemetery in Berlin lengerman was
chosen for his commitment to
reconciliation between Germany and
Britain his project titled the scar
deals with the memories of World War one
lang Amon has been able to chart the
front using his great-grandfather's
military pass his photos document the
scars of that war still visible today in
spring 1918 my great-grandfather was on
the western front fighting against
British troops and during a patrol
between the between the lines he met a
British soldier and instead on killing
each other the two boys decided to live
and they jumped in a shell hole and
smoking a cigarette and they were
waiting the Sun set and when it become
dark they both went back to their lines
and after this my great-grandfather
didn't speak about this for 56 years he
just started talking about it when his
great-grandson
asked him grant dead where you at war
even though the British destroyed his
parents hometown during World War two
Lenna man's father was one of the first
exchange students to venture into the
anglo-saxon world and Martin was also
sent on an exchange to London when he
was 10 years old the former enemies were
slowly becoming friends and for me that
was the big big adventure so I I came to
total foreign country
which was so different to Germany it was
before the globalization so they were
the the men were going to work in
pinstripes bowl ahead and umbrella and I
was just 10 years old and for me it was
a great adventure and I fell in love
with the people in the country
Martin lengerman is excited to see the
Queen he's not at all surprised that
she's so popular in Germany she loves so
much of the nature sports horses see
regular visits and the highland games
and all that sounds very relaxed to me
both Germany's president and Chancellor
will meet the Queen for a private
audience during her three-day visit
these fans aren't so lucky they like
most won't be allowed to get too close
anyone up for braving crowds can head to
Berlin's Brandenburg Gate to catch a
glimpse of the royal wave